and we it was to IDF with you and what's
happening
um I don't Frick with you
oh so you could
suffering in that but you can't say
it huh
the thing is I grew up dancing to I look
back at like videos on YouTube when I
was like 12 dancing to the most like
crazy music but at that time in dance
like I never listened to the lyrics
because every move for us is on the
Beats so I look back at like videos and
went 12 dancing to the most like insane
songs and I'm like no wonder in the
comments people are like why do you have
a 12 year old dancing to this it was the
same thing when I was younger I was
listening to two Live Crew
and uh listening to NWA Frick the police
coming down with authority
it's totally it and I would beat box
off the top sound